he sold over 30 million albums and has
won several awards including a Grammy he
has a shoe company water business film
production companies and a headphone
line he's 50 cent and here his top 10
rules for success a lot of us under
circumstances when he's starting with
the ain't no plan B [ __ ] gotta work
don't work what's going to happen you
know so if you're not point in position
you go what's working and you start to
get influenced so you sway to what's
actually working at the moment and your
music changes and starts to sound a
little bit like what's happening on the
radio right now I've heard demo tapes
from ten different little Wayne's there
wasn't Lil Wayne you know I mean I was
like the hammy yeah - it down pat that's
that sure sound like what you did you
know like I did it stuff like how do you
say that it's not good if was working
right now is that you know I'm saying so
you go and like it it's good but it's
hard for me to really embrace it because
you ain't Lil Wayne work if you want me
to invest the money in the copy
no actually go work with I thought was
ready in 97 right and I didn't have a
major record company marketing to
promote my project till 2003 right you
know so for that time period I had to be
running on my own energy you know I had
to convince myself that I I'm gonna make
it you know regardless to how people
felt at that time and what it does is it
makes you feel like what made me feel
like there's going to be points that
people don't mistake my confidence for
arrogance because I've had to they don't
understand the process I went through
and how much I had to believe in myself
in order to make these things happen I
kind of I felt like you can will
yourself into a good space things that
are meant to happen well
and you believe in yourself enough you
can help yourself learn you can inspire
yourself in different ways where you can
actually discipline yourself you know to
the point that you can become good
enough like from 97 like when I started
writing it was full-time like every day
I was writing music because I had a
choice if I was gonna stop hustling then
how was I gonna provide or create
continue the lifestyle that I created
for my son's mom my son and myself I
think the things you go to make who you
are I don't regret those things
I don't regret them because I don't
think I'd be Who I am today if I wasn't
exposed to those situations if you ask
me what i those are unfortunate
situations that I've had the experience
and if I had a choice I would have
definitely went in a different direction
I might want want to go to school for
business instead of having to go through
that this portion of my life no matter
how much you feel like you're prepared
for something it never happens on your
time but when you think you're ready
like you're supposed to happen it always
happens when it's supposed to happen
because the period did you feel ready
and people are not acknowledging the
material the way you feel like they
should because it's good it's the time
that you actually develop skin thick
enough to survive when it does work yeah
I'm not interested in the financial
Coast I want to continue success but
there's no specific mark of finances do
the work because to be honest with you
if I'm sitting here with you a year from
now two years from now and they like you
did it you're a billionaire i'ma still
be saying it but I got another idea
right a new idea and it's what I think
is representation of a person who is
truly ambitious because ambition isn't a
learned behavior it's a part of your
natural character and you always find
something to be passionate about our new
goal or new you see guys sell companies
five six billion dollars and go yeah
okay now what's the next one I'm a
rapper
entrepreneur a person that has a doesn't
see limitations I have my personalized
high expectations for myself and when I
actually start to look at some of the
things that I've accomplished and I come
a little more interest in my legacy like
what people remember me as is what made
it more important that I involved myself
in philanthropy because the people they
resonate the strongest in the absence
have done more for for people when they
were actually in good positions and it's
why I'm here there's nothing that can
actually compare to when it's right what
it feels like when when it's right the
music is just dead right and it's like
that energy that's dead man you'll
that's all so special kind of heart that
you get addicted to and you'll chase it
for the rest of your actual career when
you feel like feeling what is your first
album second album third album just a
single there's a lot of artists have a
career long enough for one song you know
but you feel what that feeling is you
ain't gonna replace it we even brought
it down to the perspective of a person
is in a staff meeting that won't this is
watching someone else raise their hand
to answer a question that they know the
answer to and that means that person
deserves to be ahead of your life
because your fear of being wrong at that
point is not allowing you to create
value guys this is crazy I grew up
without money but I didn't grow up
hungry what's going on in this world is
out of control I mean there's so many
people suffering from hunger
I mean dying from hunger every day I
went to Africa and the devastation I
witnessed changed me forever I mean you
see people who don't know when they're
gonna see their next meal or if they
don't receive their next meal it's crazy
I want to feed a billion hungry people
and I need your help to do that
this is our world these are streets
I need your energy let's do this
I should thank everybody
the support
to those done
yesterday listen a franchise-record
cheaper
and I told you people
not to listen to music and some people
didn't listen and look what happened my
leave number talked about motorcycle
after
this is the statue already
skateboarders we will ride a bike all
over the places people playing the music
try to work out don't worry I just plug
in the worst deal ever and it hurts
yours bad Lucas I love hip-hop
although else to say I beat everywhere
is that something all over please it is
because this music sucks so bad to the
kill people listen to it please you
think I'm gonna make it dude
may I probably want make advances wicked
baby I'm a hole up kid don't take me
with you
[ __ ] party
and he's off
we were talking about film you've got a
big big big film coming out very soon
yeah I did a project man look I did a
big one you did a real big one yeah I
know who you are
shadow it's been following me ever since
I was smaller the story you know
don't be afraid
he don't
I've been shot nine times I'm not afraid
in a little white girl
stop magic blah
thank you guys for watching I made this
video because quake DHH asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of
50-cents top 10 lessons are most
applicable to you which one you love
most and why leave it below I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon